inshallah
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tagalongs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in them
and my afro was picky to the night east
moschino and versace no laces in our
cheese new millennium
of course of course khabib khabib gonna
win
my brother
inshallah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys so basically guys as you can see on
this video find i found the relationship
between
khabib and ronaldinho very interesting
you know um they seem some sort of it
seems like there's some sort of
friendship there
some sort of closeness and i wanted to
also regarding this matter i wanted to
address a certain
misconception people have about can you
be friends with non-muslims now
as you can see khabib's relationship
with ronaldinho it seems close you know
they seem like you know they support
each other as
you can see that you know in
ronaldinho's live stream on instagram
he says team khabib and even says
inshallah you know if allah wills
and uh and the same day i notice in
khabib's
story where he's you know ronaldinho
taking a free kick and scoring
and they're both kind of like you know
being each other up on instagram
uh which i found very um heartwarming so
we're going to go to suraman tahina
now in this surah this explains to us
how does muslims
as us individuals how does one
um have a relationship with non-muslims
is it true that we are not allowed to
have them
as our friends uh we're going to cover
that inshallah so we're going to quickly
go through that
so in the first ayah you can see all of
the planets are saying all believers do
not take my enemies and yours as trusted
allies showing them affection even
though they deny what has come to you
come to you of truth they drove the
messenger and yourselves out of mecca
simply for your belief in allah
your lord if you truly emigrated to
struggling my cause and seek my pleasure
then do not take them as allies
disclosing secrets of the believers
to the pagans out of affection for them
and when i know
best what whatever you consider whatever
you reveal and whoever of you does
this has truly uh strayed away from the
right path so you can see here
do not take my enemies so we're talking
about any museum
so now um
okay so basically if we go to the verse
six nine ten seven uh eight to eight
here
now this is very clear for us allah says
allah does not forbid you from dealing
kindly and fairly with those who have
neither fought you nor driven you out of
your home homes
surely allah loves those who are fair
who are just
the first verse is talking about who the
enemies
of the muslims so and allah saying allah
does not forbid you from being dealing
kindly and fairly with those who neither
fought you nor
drive you out of your home surely allah
loves those who are fair
and then allah says allah only forbids
you so this is what i say in the
prohibition it only forbids you from
befriending
those who have fought you for your faith
and driven you out of your homes
or supported others in doing so and
whoever takes them as friends then it is
they who are the wrong true wrongdoers
so allah is saying do not take those who
persecuted you
as friends so this is very clear this
was not been abrogated
um so yeah guys hope you guys have um
enjoyed this video uh and inshallah make
dua that allah
guides uh ronaldinho to islam inshallah
and maybe just ask him maybe if you have
a chance go to his story and ask him
have you have you ever read the quran
would you like to read the quran and
maybe we can you know get in contact
with me and we can maybe send him
a quran um free of charge
by aira so promises let us know
inshaallah
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi
foreign